[MUSIC]
JANE COX: Theatrical
Design Studio
is a course that
mentors students
through designing a show
for the theater program
and working with a
professional creative team,
or a fellow student's, visiting
artist's creative team,
like in one of our theaters --
designing the paperwork,
drafting the light plot,
writing the light cues,
and going through a creative
process with the rest
of the design team.
Several years ago, we were
trying to decide whether or not
we should go all LED.
And at the time, lighting
technology wasn't really ready,
but we just decided
that the University
should be at the forefront
of entertainment technology.
ABIGAIL JEAN-BAPTISTE: To have
the state of the art equipment
is one thing.
But then on top of
that, we have the people
who use it professionally
telling us how to use it.
It's exciting because
it makes professionals
want to work here.
They want to see this new
building and this new space
with the best equipment that
literally across the country
has to offer.
So it really makes the Princeton
arts community stand out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]